[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs l'image que je
m'apprête à vous présenter devrait
heurter votre sensibilité
il aurait été préférable j'en conviens
dans flouté certaines parties mais je
tenais à vous montrer le tableau dans
son ensemble je tenais à vous montrer le
tableau sans le moindre artifice
enfin jeudi tableau mais je pourrais
parler de scènes de crime car c'est ce
dont il s'agit une scène de crime
impressionnant n'est-ce pas vous me
direz cela nous
pas une scène de crime conventionnel
mais laissez-moi opérer un léger zoom
qu'en dites vous
nous avons bien affaire à un crime non
un crime d'une violence et d'une ampleur
inouïe
à tel point que l'on pourrait parler de
catastrophe oui de catastrophes au sens
où les dinosaures qui ont vu arriver la
météorite l'entendent
sauf que cette fois c'est nous les
propres victimes de cette catastrophe
qui en somme les instigateurs sauf que
cette fois la météorite ne viendra pas
des profondeurs de l'espace mais de nos
poubelles de nos usines et de nos
rivières elle ne sera pas composé de
roches de glace et de métal en fusion
mais de sacs plastiques de masques
jetables et de nappes d'hydrocarbures 10
millions de tonnes
c'est la masse de déchets plastiques qui
pénètre dans les océans chaque année
depuis que ce speech super angoissant
que je en train de vous livrer a
commencé l'équivalent en volume de 12
piscines olympiques pleine à craquer de
déchets viennent de pénétrer dans les
océans de la planète
à ce rythme là les scientifiques
estiment que d'ici 2050
demain donc 99 % des animaux marins
auront ingéré du plastique d'ailleurs si
on considère le plastique qui se
trouvent dans les océans en plus de
celui que les poissons ingère bientôt
très bientôt il y aura plus de matière
plastique queue de poisson dans les mers
de la planète
notre planète bien entendu je pourrais
continuer pendant des heures à vous
livrer des faits des chiffres tous plus
alarmant les uns que les autres sur la
pollution de la planète
et qu'est ce qu'on y gagnerait au final
de la fatigue de l' angoisse peut être
même une certaine léthargie
pourtant je ne suis pas en train de vous
livrer un cours de mécanique quantique
théorique mais bien de vous livrer des
faits sur la pollution de nos océans
d'ailleurs je serais bien incapable de
vous livrer un cours de mécanique
quantique théorique ce que je peux faire
en revanche c'est essayer de vous donner
de l'espoir
mieux de faire en sorte que chacun
d'entre vous ici dans cette salle où
derrière vos écrans vous fassiez partie
de cet espoir bonjour à tous je
m'appelle baptiste jagoury je suis un
étudiant à l'estaca une école
d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans les
transports
je suis le fondateur d'un projet
étudiant de robots torture ramasseurs de
déchets dans les ports si je suis ici
devant vous aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
tant pour vous parler de mon projet mais
ce qui m'a motivé à le lancer
revenons au début si vous le voulez bien
depuis que je suis tout petit ma passion
c'est créer quel que soit le support
quel que soit le produit final j'aime me
creuser les méninges pour concevoir
quelque chose qui n'existait pas
auparavant
cela a commencé avec les lego ce qui est
assez ironique quand on sait dans quel
matériau ils sont faits puis avec le
dessin la peinture la sculpture
l'écriture et même le design graphique
j'aime créer aussi quand je suis arrivé
au lycée il m'a fallu m'interroger
comment faire en sorte que cette
créativité et d'un sens comment faire en
sorte qu'elle soit utile au départ je
visais pas forcément une utilité à mon
prochain ou à la planète
je voulais simplement que mes idées ma
créativité puisse changer quelques
choses ont bien changé quelque chose en
mieux bref s'exprimer mais j'aimais la
science et j'étais bon en sciences alors
je suis allé en terminale s la voie
royale pour les esprits scientifiques
cependant très vite je me suis rendu
compte que je n'étais pas un
scientifique être un scientifique c'est
vouloir observer comprendre et expliquer
moi je ne voulais pas percer les
mystères de la création je voulais être
créateur et quelle discipline
quelle discipline se trouve à la
frontière de la compréhension et de la
création à la frontière de la science et
de l'art l'ingéniérie bien sûr si vous
ne me croyez pas laissez moi vous
rappeler que l'ingénieur le plus célèbre
de l'histoire de l'humanité était
également le plus grand scientifique et
le plus grand artiste de son temps
ou pour le dire autrement la main qui a
peint de la joconde appartenait à la
même personne qui a observé le vol des
oiseaux pour concevoir les toutes
premières machines volantes
je suis donc rentré à l'estaca une école
d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans les
transports avec un objectif très simple
apprendre à créer à ce moment là je
n'imaginais pas que cet apprentissage je
le mettrai au service des océans je
voulais simplement comme léonard de
vinci réaliser des machines volantes
pour moi et comme pour lui la machine
volante c'est la quintessence de
l'ingénierie alors je suis rentré dans
la filière aéronautique le domaine
technique où l'on construit des avions
mais j'aimais la mer et comme vous
j'imagine j'étais conscient de l'état
dans laquelle elle se trouvait je me
disais simplement quelqu'un d'autre va
bien finir par s'en occuper à l'image de
la vaisselle sale qui reste dans l'évier
on est tous conscients du problème on se
dit simplement que ce n'est pas à nous
de le régler puisque c'est pas nous qui
avons mis ces déchets là ici en tout cas
pas directement et que quelqu'un d'autre
finira bien par le faire puis un beau
jour quelque chose nous fait prendre
conscience de la situation
quelque chose nous fait prendre
conscience de notre inaction
à part l'élément déclencheur a été une
émission de télé je pourrais pas vous
dire le titre de l'émission où la chaîne
dans laquelle elle est passée tout ce
dont je me rappelle c'est qu'on y voyait
des plongeurs des cendres en mer
méditerranée non loin des côtes avec
plein de corbeil pour ramasser les
déchets qui se trouve au fond de l'eau
et à la fin de la journée tout leur
corbeille qui était très nombreuse était
tout plein à craquer de déchets
plastiques alors dans un premier temps
comme tout le monde je me suis dit
quelle horreur sauf que ça faisait trois
ans que j'étudie à l'ingénierie je
commençais à avoir des réflexes
d'ingénieurs alors dans un second temps
je me suis dit est-ce qu'une machine ne
pourrait pas faire ça ramasser les
déchets mieux
est ce que cette machine ne pourrait pas
ressembler à un animal quitte à se
déplacer dans l'eau pourquoi pas lui
donner des traits ou des aptitudes
animal quoi de mieux pour sensibiliser
le grand public à la problématique des
déchets que de donner un robot des
caractéristiques animal cela un nom cela
s'appelle la bio inspiration et vous
savez qui d'autres pratiques et la bio
inspiration léonard de vinci
mon idole la boucle est bouclée ni une
ni deux je prends mon téléphone et
j'appelle des étudiants avec qui je
travaillais depuis un moment pour monter
un projet je leur ai exposé mon idée et
après quelques atroce nuits blanches à
attendre leur réponse
j'ai enfin constitué mon équipe ensuite
par définition puisqu'il va s'agir d'un
projet associatif
il faut qu'il soit hébergé par une
association c'est ce qui se passe dans
mon école mais c'est ce qui se passe
dans beaucoup d'autres écoles un projet
va dans une association pour recevoir un
soutien administratif et financier
j'appelle donc le président d'une
association de passionnés navale de mon
école et j'ai exposé mon idée il accepte
j'appelle deux professeurs afin qu'il
tutoie le projet et suivre les élèves il
accepte mais le projet ne n'est pas
encore officiellement pour cela il faut
qu'ils soient définies clairement dans
les semaines qui suivent mes camarades
et moi même nous nous creusons la tête
nous cherchons quel animal pourrait nous
servir d'inspiration très vite nous nous
arrêtons sur la tortue de mer
pourquoi la tortue de mer c'est très
simple la tortue nerfs est une véritable
danse de danseuse elle est très agile
elle sait parfaitement se déplacer dans
les trois dimensions sous l'eau mieux
son corps est rigide et creux ce qui est
idéal pour servir de contenants à
déchets c'est horrible de le dire mais
mère nature a optimisé ses animaux pour
qu'il soit capable de ramasser les
déchets et puis d'ailleurs l'idée de
concevoir un robot tortue qui va
ramasser ce sur quoi les tortues ne
devrait jamais tomber nous plaît
beaucoup
alors c'est décidé
la tortue de mer sera notre muse le
projet green turtle aînés le chemin est
long jusqu'à la mise la mise à l'eau de
ce robot un an et demi après le
lancement du projet nous n'avons encore
aucun prototype fonctionnel mais nos
modèles 3d sont terminés et nous
commençons à rentrer en contact avec des
entreprises pour acquérir du matériel
fabriqué des pièces et recevoir de l'
expertise sur ce que nous avons déjà
fait d'ailleurs là où ce projet est
fantastique c'est que nous n'avons même
pas besoin de faire beaucoup d'efforts
pour contacter les entreprises
c'est elle qui nous rejoignent pour
s'associer alors bien sûr les cons la
situation sanitaire et les confinements
successifs ont freiné leurs ardeurs
mais elle commence à revenir et le
projet repart de plus belle
d'ailleurs au delà des entreprises nous
avons aussi un fort impact médiatique
alors même que nous n'avons pas de robot
c'est important de le dire nous avons
plus d'une soixantaine d'articles dans
la presse une dizaine de passages radio
et quatre passages à la télévision dont
un en dehors de la de l'europe
deux ong l'une basée à oslo et l'autre à
hong kong nous ont même contacté pour
acheter des robes aux tortues pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai dû refuser
de donner de la documentation en
mandarin cet exemple celui de ce projet
étudiant montre bien que les
technologies les projets de protection
de l'environnement de protection des
océans ont le vent en poupe
je ne sais pas si green turtle va
marcher mais je sais une chose c'est que
j'ai bien fait de le lancer
quand j'ai démarré dans ce projet je
n'étais qu'un étudiant de troisième
année dont l'expérience professionnelle
se limitait à quelques jobs d'été et 2
expérience de stage découverte de
l'entreprise
je n'avais aucune légitimité ni
professionnel ni scolaire puisque je
n'étais qu'à la moitié de ma formation
mais avec le recul je me dis que c'est
justement ce qui a fait ma force
les études ne doivent pas se résumer au
partiel et aux stages n'attendons pas
d'être diplômé pour monter quelque chose
bien au contraire peut-être que nous
sommes jamais aussi libre de créer et de
lancer des projets qui réveille des
projets qui secoue des projets qui ont
du panache qu'au moment de nos études
c'est le moment ou jamais pour lancer
des projets des initiatives en faveur de
l'environnement en faveur de la planète
souvent j'ai entendu dire que notre
génération était né sentant trop tard
pour explorer la terre et sentant trop
tôt pour explorer l'univers
moi je pense qu'elle est pile au bon
moment pour sauver la planète
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]